dog adoptions are currently on pause for
the time being Victoria Saha outside the
foundation with more on what's going on
respiratory illness right now there are
no dogs allowed to be fostered or
adopted up and we just found out not too
long ago that the animal foundation
actually found out last Wednesday about
a foster dog that was sick and still
fostering and adoptions continued
hundreds of animals were sent home with
Foster or adopted families in a span of
a week but could those animals be at
risk since they were likely in the
shelter around the time the respiratory
illness started my do you plan to go to
my veterinarian after this and get some
antibiotics to hopefully prevent
anything from happening it's a worry for
foster and adoptive parents like
Jennifer blakerd she says she found out
about the illness Monday when the animal
foundation posted online saying 16 dogs
are symptomatic they need to let us know
what is going on so we can take these
measures she took her foster dog home on
Thursday September 29th but on Tuesday
afternoon the animal foundation says
they learned of a sick Foster dog on
Wednesday September 20 the eighth the
sick Foster dog had symptoms so severe
it had to be put down two days later
they learned the dog had tested positive
for strep zoo and canine numeral virus
both contagious but adoptions and
fostering continued I was very
frustrated and angry because you let me
take an animal home that possibly could
have been sick Natasha Greiner tells me
she picked up her dog Saturday what's
your biggest fear that my other animals
are going to get sick
and I lose everyone the spread of
disease was a concern for former CEO of
the animal foundation James Pumphrey
before he says he was let go he stated
in his July report parvovirus was being
spread by sick animals to healthy ones
due to poor infectious disease
management how the respiratory illness
spread currently is still unclear but
for now the animal foundation says they
are quarantining any dog at the shelter
that may have been exposed to the
initial case
foreign
as for that Foster owner of that dog
that had to be put down I did get a
chance to speak with her off camera she
says she's obviously still very
distraught but her dog's symptoms
worsened soon after she brought him home
and for the animals here that are
showing symptoms the animal foundation
says they have not been euthanized and
they are currently all on antibiotics
Victoria Saha 8 News Now